singer are Kelly now faces 11 new counts
of sexual assault and abuse these are
the most serious charges to be filed
after decades of abuse accusations CTM
national correspondent that's Jericka
Duncan is outside the Cook County
Courthouse in Chicago Jukka what could
these new charges mean for our Kelly
good morning Gail simply it could mean
more time behind bars some of those new
counts could mean up to 30 years in
prison now the alleged victim in this
new indictment is one of the four women
that Kelly was already accused of
abusing back in February if I was about
to brush my teeth I had to let Rob know
if I wanted to take a shower he had to
know in the docu-series surviving are
Kelly jaronda pace detailed Kelly's
alleged sexual abuse from 2010 when she
was a minor Rob slapped me and he choked
me inside blacked out in a Facebook post
yesterday Pei said the new charges
against Kelly including aggravated
criminal sexual assault and abuse are
related to her case she wrote no matter
how wrong you think I am the law is on
my side a minor at the time Kelley's
attorney Steve Greenberg tells CBS News
the charges alleged Kelly choked and
forced the victim to perform oral sex on
him on several occasions
Kelly denies any wrongdoing in February
the 52 year old singer turned himself in
to Chicago police after he was charged
with 10 counts of sexual abuse which
involved four women some of them minors
in a tearful and sometimes combative
interview with Gayle King in March
Kelly forcefully denied all allegations
against him have you ever had sex of
anyone under the age of 7 no never no
Kelly's attorney said on Twitter the new
charges are the same conduct just
charged differently same alleged victim
same time frame same facts we expect the
same results attorney Michael avenatti
represents at least one of the alleged
victims in the previous indictment I
expect additional charges beyond that
these most recent charges to be issued
in the next 30 days at the federal level
what can we expect when you say that
there's more to come with federal
charges
we believe that the most serious charges
have yet to be issued and will be issued
against our Kelly now avenatti faces
accusations of extortion and stealing
and unrelated charges which he denies
Kelly remains free on 1 million dollars
bond he is due back here in court next
Thursday Anthony all right drinketh ank
you